hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Mario maker now I
asked you guys on face huh why do I want
to say dies I asked you dies I asked to
you guys what levels I should play on
Facebook don't ask why I'm talking like
this it's because I can't enunciate so I
picked out some good levels for me to
play and now I am going to play them now
ha ha ha okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier um so I took your suggestions
for games that I should play but you
pointed me to a website that Nintendo
made where you can actually look up good
levels so I did that bookmark them and
they're ranked from kind of hard to
obscenely hard down at the bottom so I'm
gonna play those now and not talk about
this anymore or try to do this intro
ever again because I can't do this I've
made almost 3,000 okay anyway
oh hello okay okay I always did admit
Supergirl not yet I can't do this
no not failure Oh No okay so I I will
admit Super Mario World is probably my
favorite level archetype oh okay well
off to a bad start
why am I so bad oh I could just see
Mario whenever I load up this game is
like oh no no this a loser
I can't dude I can't do it I can't so no
one please question anything that I just
did cuz oh come on
throwing your boners at me Oh like I
didn't that guy didn't do be affected by
that at all
so if what was I even talking about
anyway Super Mario World
yeah it's my favorite kind of level type
because I always thought the design was
very pleasant and I have a lot of good
memories of me and my brother playing
this particular game so whenever I get a
chance to play Super Mario maker level
with this and to be frank I have not
made my own level oh god not again oh I
could have made that over there right
FAK oh that's not helpful well me being
bad probably isn't helpful to my entire
Oh Oh No okay hey I got your little game
oh look at the happy little clouds in
the background
aren't they just adorable oh dammit god
dammit why do I have to be so bad at
this look at me speed demon Markab oh
god this is the worst I knew I shouldn't
have tried challenging levels but okay I
got this under wraps because I actually
do know what I'm doing
contrary to probably popular opinion
down in the comments below I do have
some inkling of how to play Mario Oh
but anyway me and uh I did want to talk
about me and uh me Ryan and Matt have
been taking improv classes lately and
that's been dominating a lot of my time
but it is really it is really fun to try
to it is really fun to try to learn more
about the elements of comedy as opposed
to anything that I can just come up with
on the fly because it's like it's like
it's like it's an interesting cross
because from what I've been doing like
on YouTube and the like what I've been
doing here pretty much my entire youtube
career is basically improv I play a game
and then I make up everything on the fly
usually just from the fact that I'm so
terrible at games but I make everything
up and it's an odd analogy to what I'm
doing an improv class because I'm like
applying what I've learned and what I've
learned is that I've kind of been doing
everything right already not that I'm a
professional improv er I don't want to
like try to even Ramon [ __ ] to even
remotely say that I'm good at improv or
good at a professional comedian in any
capacity because I'm definitely not but
what is interesting is that the skills
that I've developed as an as a let's
player kind of lead a lot to me being
good in the improv class but contrary to
that is the fact that I
oh no no no no I go back thank you
please say got a mushroom out that what
was I saying oh no oh no oh what fresh
hell is this oh god do I get it I
probably got it yeah yeah yeah okay all
right I got this I'm good I think this
one had a fiber okay I got you
poink head oink huh boink yes Oh God
nothing no one had another one okay so
anyway what I was saying about improv is
it I've been a big fan of improv for
pretty much my entire no that's that's
opposite that's oddly not I've been a
big fan of improv for any much in my
entire life because improv and
especially like I mean the default is
whose line is it anyway that's like
obviously a lot a lot of people's first
introduction to what improv is is whose
line and that's not a bad one Oh God oh
it was so scary well thank you wait no
God
Frick god dammit Oh Frank
I was doing so good I'm here I'm so
frazzled brained when I'm playing Oh
Mario maker but a lot of people's first
introduction to improv is whose line is
in anyway and that's not a bad thing but
that's short short form improvisation
and one of the things that I learned is
the difference between short-form and
long-form and that's like long-form is
about creating a story and a narrative
out of nothingness
whereas short form is kind of doing the
same thing but I can't do it to save my
life where long forms doing a long
narrative in short form is playing games
and improvising both take a lot of
improvisational skill and what I've been
doing kind of leads itself to short form
very well but learning about long form
narrative is actually fun because it can
help with like skills in terms of trying
to write
sketches a little better which something
that I very much enjoy doing and that
being said oh god should I be should I
be doing this oh that's a bunch of [ __ ]
douchey oh what a [ __ ] douche okay
anyway so like it's interesting because
obviously script writing is very
important for many things on YouTube
that are better than Let's Plays
probably that's all very subjective and
I won't get into anything opinion based
as such as that as the such such as the
Iraq okay I did something oh man
oh look short stuff gonna get it okay
but short form is interesting because
it's what a lot of let's playing is
because you're literally playing a game
and then playing off of it and your seam
partner is the game especially when I'm
here by myself and uh Danny Danny is
actually a very very very well played
improviser and he and that level was
really fun by the way he's a very
professionally trained to improviser as
well as ninja Brian and so it's really
interesting to see from both
perspectives what that's like him what
that leads to so it's really interesting
me to see all that it was really
interesting to learn more about it
because improvisation is always a big
thing in my life with me and Ryan the
mat just hanging out we always just joke
around and make up a random Bowl that
we're doing at any old time in any old
capacity so it's really nice to be more
trained about it that being said there
are people in that class that are way
funnier than I am like wait funnier like
I couldn't even imagine being like whoa
hey whoa whoa I don't know what those
are I've never seen those in my life
that's probably a trap
that's a trap Oh God okay all right I
bonk my head oh that's adorable so yeah
there are people that are like obviously
there are people that you know try
harder and know more than I do as it is
but that's not to say that we're bad
goddamn and I'd have no idea what I'm
saying all say is that we're taking it
Brooke damn it well that went exactly as
everyone probably expected it to do at
home [ __ ] I'm so bad
judging me Oh improv is such an
accepting and open environment that this
is obviously an environment of judgement
ation with the yuku to you you could
Tube comments and whatnot and what have
you and as such the iran and iraq god
my life is under chaos oh i love whose
line i love it it's always been my
favorite show I could watch any episode
of that forever and ever and I would be
totally happy with my life like that's
how much I love the show and I never
even realize Frank you son of a beeswax
okay I never even realized like how much
I already like had an affinity for
improv oh gosh dang it
okay and once again don't want to say
that I'm good but it's fun on a bun and
I'm trying to concentrate here so
everybody just hush pie holes for a
goddamn second Oh
uh-huh oh thank ya huh
boink thank you am I supposed to so am I
uh that makes a lot more sense than what
I was going for over there okay oh hey
stay away from me you big greenie
bastard you're like one of the Rings
from off hey good for me okay what was I
saying
god damn it I don't even remember some
of it about something of improvisation
but anyway yeah so uh yeah I'm certain
being uh with Matt and Ryan through that
but Bryan being the bit of a doof that
he is and admittedly I have mocked Ryan
very mercilessly especially on this
particular playthrough and you know not
entirely to his discredit on that one
but you know he is deserving of some
some criticism on here and there why
what am I even talking about you know
I'm gonna take a step back because I'm
feeling I'm probably getting pretty
close Oh God oh okay can't be me Oh
Frick oh god stop beating me
yeah no no oh god oh god oh god it's
terrible
upper tires what is this fruit sonic oh
god oh god everything is just a sheer
panic from start to finish for me I have
no control over anything that I'm saying
because any time that I'm faced with
anything even slightly like problematic
I instantly go into panic mode my brain
is just like oh no yes yes okay there we
go now I got it okay am I almost done
yeah okay there we go okay so that's
what I was talking about man I have a
lot more things that I wanted to talk
about besides that but my brain just
gotten a little bit of bit dizzy at the
moment but one thing that I didn't want
to say is that I am selling brand new
shirts look at that look at that
Matt zoom in on that look at that I'm
selling actually two different versions
of shirts this one is the dog one it's
adorable
and is amazingly well crafted I love it
to death it's made by Lin's bot and it's
actually a competing shirt because
there's a cat version of this but I
wanted to wear the dog versions shirt
because puppies are my favorite so it's
gonna be like a cat vs. dog shirt a
competition thing but no matter what who
wins I will be donating $10,000 to the
Best Friends Animal Society because
animals are amazing I love chica being
in my life she's added a lot of joy Ryan
got Lego and now we have two amazing
dogs in the house and matt has a kitty
cat so let me know what you like the
most by picking the shirt that you want
and I'll come up with a way for one to
win in a future episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see
we don't have anymore inflatable rocks
blocking my way